ton parent à angers où emmanuel macron
est en train de s'exprimer il est dans
un centre de réfugiés
ukrainien on écoute le
président-candidat
taxation à cause des bombes et de
l'agression russe
et ces femmes et ces hommes fuient à
travers l'europe et je crois que notre
quand même pas je sais que notre devoir
est de pouvoir les accueillir les
protéger dans les meilleures conditions
possibles la france comme je les dis
depuis le début de cette guerre prendra
sa part et nous la prenons
nous nous sommes mises en capacités je
veux remercier le ministre de
l'intérieur et la ministre déléguée
d'avoir piloté ce travail qui est
éminemment interministériel et a aussi à
côté d'eux l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement concernés mais nous sommes
mis en capacité déjà de mobiliser les
premières places d'accueil et c'est un
travail qui se fait conjointement avec
nos élus partout sur le territoire avec
évidemment les services de l'état avec
les associations qui font ce travail est
souvent aussi avec la solidarité très
concrète des françaises et des français
nous nous sommes mis en situation de
pouvoir accueillir au moins cent mille
crânienne ukrainien mais nous prendrons
comme je les dis notre part et nous
protégerons celles et ceux qui arrivent
sur notre sol et nous aurons aussi une
solidarité à avoir à l'égard des pays
qui aujourd'hui sont le plus sous
pression nous avons pris des engagements
en particulier à l'égard de la moldavie
qui a accueilli beaucoup de de réfugiés
ces dernières semaines et que nous
allons aider dans les prochains jours en
reprenant
des femmes des enfants des hommes pour
les protéger et donc vous le voyez
l'union européenne est mobilisé c'est
organisé très vite nous avons organisé
la solidarité européenne et
les structures juridiques nous nous
sommes organisés en européens pour
pouvoir donner des titres provisoires
protégeant celles et ceux qui arrivent
sur notre sol et nous sommes en train
d'organiser la présidence française avec
la commission et l'ensemble de nos
collègues est bien là
le partage de l'effort que tous les
européennes tous les européens doivent
mettre en oeuvre pour accueillir dans
les meilleures conditions dans les
prochains jours et les prochaines
semaines nous allons continuer et
poursuivre ce travail qui est d'abord un
travail d'accueil de permettre ces
femmes et ces hommes d'arriver dans les
meilleures conditions de pouvoir avoir
un hébergement d'urgence et de pouvoir
instruire leurs droits je veux remercier
l'ensemble des services de l'état qui
ont pour raccourcir les délais pour que
dans les temps les plus rapides en lien
avec justement les associations les
travailleurs sociaux nous puissions
faire ce travail très vite ensuite c'est
de permettre de soigner celles et ceux
qui en ont besoin on évoquait tout à
l'heure mais importante fait que des des
enfants des adolescents des femmes des
hommes arrivent avec des traitements
dont ils ont besoin qu'il faut pouvoir
très vite
restabiliser est donné donc c'est la
santé c'est évidemment l'hébergement et
de la stabilité c'est ensuite de
l'éducation et donc nous allons
mobiliser nos communes notre éducation
nationale à cette fin et c'est de
permettre par l'apprentissage de la
langue et le travail de donner aussi une
stabilité une place une dignité le plus
vite possible
c'est tout cela l'accueil est donc vous
le voyez cela va nous mobiliser dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent nous
en avons la capacité nous en avons le
devoir et je pense que cette fraternité
est aussi notre dignité collective donc
à nouveau je veux vraiment ici remercier
l'ensemble des associations qui font ce
travail
remercié les services de l'état
remercier nos élus remercier
travailleurs sociaux les bénévoles et
nos compatriotes qui je le sais sont
très mobilisés dans ce moment
particulièrement éprouvant pour notre
europe mais surtout ce moment terrible
pour les ukrainiennes les ukrainiens aux
côtés desquels nous nous tenons